changez l'eau tous les deux jours on
recoupe un peu les tiges comme
l'habitude ça vous fait 10 euros merce
comme tous les vendredis matins elvina
vend des fleurs sur le marché de
montbard
la jeune femme n'a pas de boutique fixe
depuis le mois de mai elle installe son
flower trucks un jour ici le lendemain
ailleurs dans le nord de la côte d'or où
dans l'yonne un vrai fois moi c'était
une évidence d'être dans un milieu rural
je me voyais même si j'ai fait mes
études dans les grandes villes à lyon
j'ai travaillé à dijon je me voyais pas
vivre en ville toute ma vie elvina
habite à châtillon-sur-seine de retour
des marchés tous les après midi c'est
chez elle dans son petit atelier qu'elle
prépare les commandes à livrer des
compositions souvent inspiré par ses
promenades dans la campagne
la nature elle nous offre beaucoup de
choses par exemple toutes les branches
la sas est un client qui me les a
données qu'il est taillé de ces boules
au fond c'est vrai qu'en ville c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué même un simple
feuillage il faut l'acheter dame ousse
des bois il faut l'acheter alors que moi
j'ai juste à me balader une petite après
midi quand j'ai le temps et j'ai tout
quoi je vais vous montrer les meubles le
bois et johanna c'est une histoire de
famille
on a une scierie moi je suis la
quatrième génération donc c'est mon papa
son frère et ses cousins qui qui sont à
la gérance de cette entreprise et donc
oui moi j'ai toujours baigné là dedans
et elle a attrapé le virus de la
création d'entreprise
il y a deux ans elle a ouvert avec sa
tante un magasin spécialisé dans
l'aménagement et la décoration
rien que du bois et les productions
familiales en bonne place forcément
travailler dans le châtillonnais
elle n'y voit aujourd'hui que des
avantages bien plus qu'en ville en tout
cas n'avait pas cet esprit de
convivialité de solidarité aussi parce
que on est très solidaire quand on bat
vraiment quand on est dans une petite
ville que tout le monde se connaît on a
vite fait d'appeler un copain vient
m'aider à faire si c'est des choses
qu'on n'a pas faux que j'ai pas
forcément retrouver en ville quand j'ai
passé mes deux ou trois années à dijon
et puisque ici tout le monde se connaît
johanna sait très bien qui est la petite
fleuriste nomades
les deux jeunes femmes sont même devenus
amis